I am from Texas Grand Prairie Texas when
I was about six or seven years old I
asked my mom if I could be on the TV and
she said all right we'll try it and I've
been here ever since I'd like to think
of something I never thought before what
was your first job at Barney Barney
purple dinosaur when we first met Selena
the 14 year old was at the very
beginning of the Disney career this
audition tape landed her first big role
why is a me always included in we the
only thing we are doing is going to the
concert I hear you got a big project
coming up yes it's a new Disney Channel
show dudes of waverly place I'm playing
Alex Russo and she's the one always
getting in trouble with the family she
uses magic to get out of situation she
was a child star but definitely not
spoiled Lena's mom Mandy gave birth to
her at 16 and worked three jobs
sacrificing it all for her family I was
the Teen Mom I was like okay I have
another person depending on me
I gotta get straight but here's the
thing about growing up Disney Selena had
some pretty interesting relationships
with her fellow Disney kids
Demi Lovato Nick Jonas and Miley Cyrus
throw in Taylor Swift and you've got one
big mess
so pay attention because this gets kind
of intense now in 2002 Selena and Demi
we're besties hey what's up its Selena
Gomez and Demi Lovato and this is my
best friend in the entire world my
friend yes ever since we were 7 years
old I'm Barney it's the band here not
yet
oh I can't wait to he didn't because
someday I want to play the battleship
Timmy's my best friend clearly I have
such a connection with her and she's
always there for me
2008 the two started posting a bunch of
vlogs and analysts to know what our
favorite food is pickles but then enter
Miley who basically made fun of the two
yo yo yo yo yo yo get ready to rock and
roll
the reason for the feud may be because
of a love triangle you see back then
both stars had a thing for this guy
gomez Cyrus Cyrus Gomez Syrus Gomez no
Miley Nix split in 2007 then in 2008
Selena started dating the Joe bro that
romance introduced her to her new BFF
Taylor who was seeing Joe at the same
time Demi was not happy yeah jealous
much well over the next few years Selena
and Demi followed and unfollowed each
other on social media right now the two
seem to have ended their feud all smiles
they reunited in late October at the
InStyle Awards
it's a very hard time sometimes for
women because all they want is to just
pin each other against each other and
it's just 2011 was the beginning of
Bieber I'm always one err to do the best
chicken babe the two would make up and
break up several times all throughout
Jelena was super private about the
relationship but we had our ways of
getting Selena to talk is it true you're
dating Justin Bieber okay whenever and
I'll be there the baby Justin Bieber
August 2016 Selena went to rehab it was
her second time and she spent three
months at a Tennessee medical facility
she said she was having anxiety panic
attacks and depression as a result of
her lupus
Selena gave up her phone for 90 days did
group therapy sessions and emerged
stronger and more confident everything
you know my personal
my friends I'm just I'm a really happy
place it's been good can't keep my hands
to myself 2017 has been the year of new
beginnings in September Selina revealed
that her best friend gave her a kidney
transplant and saved her life the doctor
said that 50 percent of my recovery will
be mentality it inspired me it motivated
me and I I wanted to get through it in a
way where I felt empowered
in October after ten months of dating
Selena and the weekend broke up they
unfollowed each other on social media
and then four weeks later Selena started
exclusively dating the beads again in
Billboard magazine the 25 year old talks
about her relationship with Justin
saying maybe before it could have been
forcing something that wasn't right but
that doesn't mean caring for someone
ever goes away I like to come at things
with my best that's all I know how to do
is just give my best
[Music]